I wanted to kick her out but I didn't
know you didn't shut up you're a nice
person I'm Roxanne I'm Wyatt time
Frankie won Francisco Frankie - and
we've been together for about a year and
a half we've been together about nine
months today we are talking about the
dumbest fight we've ever had there was
one time when we went on our first day
and because of Roxanne I crashed my car
it didn't really turn to an argument but
I'm pretty sure it was her fault for not
telling me that there was a car on my
side I think we're gonna start an
argument talking about this but yeah I
remember on our first date it was going
really well it was really cute he like
took me to San Francisco for a dinner
and like we were trying to park our car
to go okay his car just like in my car
and I was trying to parallel park so I
was backing in like this and then she
was looking back like this and then she
doesn't say nothing nothing comes out of
her mouth and the next thing I know it
goes boom I hit the whole front end of a
car and then she was just like oh my god
there's a car there okay no one told me
I was supposed to you know be on the
lookout I thought you were like a
skilled parallel Parker I was probably
thinking about how good the date was
going he took it pretty well I mean his
car like it did end up getting like
super scratch and he didn't blame me for
it
yeah didn't blame her like we did have
like a bit of back and forth I think it
was more back and forth after we were
together yeah like we keep revisiting I
still wanted to go on a date with her
but I didn't want to be like maybe crash
my car yeah we did all my work yeah we
did like during the day like he wasn't
looking out but afterwards like it's
been something that I've been salty
about for a long time you should have
been looking you should have called out
I think I want forever I'll take it to
the grave for every sake that I had to
pay my insurance $500 how is this my
fault because you didn't say my thing
suppose if there's a car back in there I
guess I'm like just like the designated
lookout I'm still gonna be salty okay I
have the one that's different than his
but it involves food and hang greenness
and I think you know what I'm talking
about they're having like a couple days
of document I had just got enough work
and this dude was like I'm hungry I want
to go get food so he wanted to get
subway we've been planning to get to
wait for like ever and so he got to the
subway and the subway was closed so I
was like okay we'll get something else
weird way to the next day for pride like
really early in the more
and so I was like well we can't really
go anywhere so then I got home and then
he got home and he was just mad I was
like what's wrong he's like that way it
was closed I want to eat something I was
like well we can't go nowhere and he's
like well we can call a car and I was
like I think I misunderstood him and I
was like well I can't call a car right
now we were proceeding to get ready and
take a shower and so I was like not
talking to him kind of he was mad and so
the shower was running but I was looking
at places to eat and I was like you want
to go to Taco Bell he's like he was just
ignore me you're not even listening and
the shower was still running I was
sitting on the toilet and I was not on
the toilet sitting on the toilet he was
like the shower is on and I was like I
know the waters running I turned it on
I'll pay that water is that about yeah I
was hungry and I wanted to be like baby
like I want him to be like yes let's go
get food right now instead it was like
no we shouldn't go this place is closer
no it's far I mean it could be babied
sometimes but to a grown-ass woman yeah
how does babe you later
okay I know a crazy story this is on her
part it was crazy but one time we got in
the fight I wake up at 4 a.m. to knock
on my door and I'm like what is that and
it was her she flew all the way down I
was in LA and he's in Sacramento and I
literally took a flight and surprised
him to like fix it before he was going
to Europe wow this is probably like the
most had like extra thing I've ever done
but yeah wheelie caudally I've kind of
spent a small argument I think it was a
few days before my finals too and I
literally just like books a last-minute
flight the night before and empty out my
bank account because it was really
expensive I was crazy I was like three
months into a relationship that was
insane
it was literally insane I think we fix
things immediately because he knew I
made that afraid of miscue yeah it was
careful cause really to the accident
this happen at Long Beach pride so he
had bought this like ugh okay he had
bought this t-shirt that's like it's
like a mesh kind of top it was a moment
I thought about a thrift store I thought
it would be cool our future desolations
like fish from the ocean
it was like a crop top macoraba yeah he
had brought it home he's like like I
bought this and I was like ugly and then
he got really upset he's like why would
you just shoot on my things like that
like I really liked it like come long
beach weekend he brought up that
Rittenhouse all his friends and they
were all like it's ugly and I was like
aimin why you man
I built up never worry about it I
thought it was cool it's still ugly and
he was mad that whole evening I will not
forget you were like not talking to me
that's like it's just an ugly shirt and
you were like what if I said you were
it's ugly you're like not everything you
wear I like and I was like you don't
gotta like 'hey you don't have the same
opinion i think we've had some like
really extra moments they never thought
of me more you know face but not a lot
of arguments so that's good I guess
advice to people out there don't argue
with your girl chill win yeah slowly and
I love him so it's never really like
never that serious it's my best friend
so yeah you made me the right on video
right now
[Music]